hello everyone thank you so much for
coming to hang out with us here at et
live on Danny direct oh I'm Lauren Zima
I'm seviche Lacey the Grammy Awards just
ended and we are coming to you live to
give you guys a recap of the most talked
about moments the biggest performances
we're still kind of shook over there was
an emotional night we're gonna go
through you guys and of course we want
to know what you thought do you agree
with us do you not what were your
favorite performances who did you wish
perform to Beyonce leave your questions
and comments for us we're gonna get them
here on our iPad and we want to interact
with you about this so well let's talk
about the big winner of the night Bruno
Mars big night for Bruno Mars performed
with cardi B won all of these huge
awards we've got album of the year
record of the year song of the year not
a lot of us and I think I speak for us
at ETL I and a lot of Grammy people out
there who were they really put Kendrick
Lamar versus jay-z for album of the year
they but I think with Bruno winning that
kind of shows that as much as relevant
as those two albums were to the time and
culture music you can't resist some fun
yes he said that he wanted to
acknowledge the lyricist who had
inspired him like babyface like these
people who just wrote songs from a place
of joy that's how he closed the Grammys
just now I would have given him a Grammy
for that that little shoulder move he
knows but I can't do in the finesse
video you do it better than me ya know
but you know props to him you know the
Grammys obviously love him but this is
the first time he has taken like these
swept I should say these top three
categories so good on him and like I
said that man is a showman you saw in
the performance tonight um and you just
cannot you know you you can't not dance
to a Bruno Mars record everyone listen
to it and not clearly the Grammy voters
listen so and you know congratulations
are also in order for Alessia Cara you
called this one but we parted the other
big category of the night I think she
was having an amazing time know she had
so much fun and this is the best part
about this win and she kind of mentioned
this on in in her speech she said that
you know she's been holding fake Grammys
taking a shower giving these fake
speeches forever and now she's up there
collecting wine and she actually told us
that that's exactly what happened when
she was growing up she talked to
et's camera matheson and the shell
turner on the red carpet before the show
and said she used to daydream about
winning a Grammy take a look yes Best
New Artist nominee wildest dream you
think you'd be here yeah I never never
thought it would be possible like I
would like daydream about winning a
Grammy one day or even like being here
so the fact that I am here is like
really weird I haven't I haven't
processed it it's very I feel like it's
really weird you're you a weird dream
that has come true miss Cara I love her
I think she's so talented she's only 21
she's so young I've interviewed her
before here's why I'm a little bit of a
hater I interviewed her I think about
two years ago on a red carpet yeah this
did not scream best new artist to me I
was here for colleague who is you know
at 19 a whole two years younger than her
but his album burst onto the scene he
didn't have anybody featured on that
album it was a hit he's an amazing
lyricist he's awesome and the biggest
thing to me is he is a new artist I just
feel like she is not that best new
artist but I know you told me that the
requirements have changed
yeah the requirements are always a
little bit interesting right now what
they're and they have changed over the
years right now to be considered a new
artist you have to have released at
minimum five songs or one album but no
more than 30 songs or three albums so
theoretically you can release three
albums and still be considered new
artists what they're really looking for
is somebody who had a huge like career
making year they should know and that
was my argument Alessia she had so many
singles on the charts right now this
early I should say in 2017 the year of
contention so I was I was baking on her
you know I liked you guys I think this
girl's gonna have a long long career a
lot of them are but like I saw her
gracing that stage tonight and it came
true by the way rich cello or Rick Ellis
are even saying your name wrong good now
but Bruno is the next Michael Jackson
has given us some MJ vibes some King of
Pop vibes in his outfit but tonight in
the audience with the curly hair yes
no doesn't love I loved it emoni where
Caesar would have won Best New Artist or
something she's great I mean we can't
deny the the amazing sisse
she was nominated for five Grammys
tonight the most of any female this year
at the Grammys so props her an amazing
performance that's the artist was a
competitive cat everyone's one of my
favorite new artists are Beyonce
No ah listen jay-z was nominated for
eight Grammys did not take home any
which is kind of crazy the most
nominated person most nominated person
tonight he didn't even grease the stage
as a performer I was banking on a jay-z
and Beyonce collab maybe I don't see
only few but thankfully we got Queen B
and Blue Ivy up in the audience just
slinging their looks you guys um I think
we have a photo of it actually a blue
and Beyonce in the audience B was
rocking all black ah dramatic hat these
giant earrings and glasses guys she's
dripping in over six million dollars of
Lorraine Schwartz jewelry can I say they
cut to her at first so quickly and from
far away I mostly saw hat and I thought
it was Lady Gaga at first that's a very
Gaga outfit to me it is my first thought
was that looks like a woman in mourning
came from a funeral
who's shooting mourning that jay-z was
not gonna win your wife died she's
mourning tonight that's you know what
maybe jay-z walked away with the
consolation puppy which no and they're
winning because their child also stole
the show tonight
there was this moment where it was right
during Camilla Kibeho was talking on the
Grammys stage and you could see blue
just kind of like look to her parents
but like simmer down because I get you
guys here it is for you guys right now
watch this watch closely blue is in
charge okay listen mom and dad we are at
the Grammy Awards I love to know what
little blue was saying was she's
silencing them was she blessing dad
we're good dad it's okay we're gonna get
you more Grammys one day it's alright I
mean can we watch it one more I think
blue is just trying to enjoy her night
out it's like these twins are driving me
up the wall I got to be an adult for a
night with you to like yeah please yeah
she's like please I need a moment of
peace she's amazed how bad I was my
favorite song of the
yes j-bay and blue do not get on the
stage they steal the show
I also got to talk about another moment
another lady who provided a lot of
moments stealing the show
miss cardi B you guys if you want to
talk about someone who's having a moment
it's cardi B so she performed of course
the finesse remix tonight with Bruno
Mars but u2 was all over the Grammys
performance and all over cardi B's
Instagram check out this video that she
posted getting a letter from Bono
cardies reaction you just have to watch
it for yourself my god I gotta know
nobody talk to me now
and we both in our name start with the
Beatles we hate to censor cardi but we
had two on that one but you guys first
of all if you don't follow her on
Instagram she is so genuine so real her
social media is to me part of the reason
she's having such a moment she's my
favorite fangirl and I hope she that
never goes away
she's the real MVP right now I brought
this realness to every red carpet
interview this whole Grammy weekend
every single time we've seen her she's
been real fresh
she was real honest about how bad she
wanted to win so I'm a little sad that
she didn't win right but always
hilarious she taught us how nervous she
was before the performance - this was at
the Clive Davis party and obviously at
the Clive Davis party jay-z was being
honored so he asked her you party the
Beehive and cardi B said oh I am the
vice president of the Beehive I go
alright then I'm treasurer she have the
best way of owning herself being proud
of herself but in the most humble way we
asked her what are you most excited for
about the Grammys and she said oh well
me to be there she's amazing and of
course her performance with Bruno Mars
let's just play a little moment of that
right now
[Music]
yes he can't not think wearing some
custom 90s Couture there okay that
costume it's amazing a lot looked
amazing and she just killed it I can't
imagine you've got to be even with your
cardi B and you have that confidence a
little nervous for your first big
Grammys performance and she absolutely
nailed it nervous for her she admitted
to being there that's another thing she
was really honest about she admitted to
being super nervous about it got out
there killed it someone agrees with us
by the way cardi B killed that say so
did Bruno that performance was a
highlight we ran again to some more
performances yes lot of pressure to
because Bruno always brings a you know
that he's gonna deliver this epic moment
consistently and for her as kind of a
newcomer to come out and hold her own
with him like a cartoon and of course
the show did get political you guys are
saying you loved Cash's performance
cache of his goals we'll talk that Lady
Gaga's as well but let's talk a little
bit about this of fire and fury readings
sketch that we had of course James
Corden doing a wonderful hilarious job
bringing levity and bringing humor to
hosting tonight but there was this
sketch with a surprise appearance by one
cardi B and one miss Hillary Clinton
let's take a look he had a longtime fear
of being poisoned
[Applause]
[Music]
you could hear the cheers in the crowd
they're basically different celebrities
reading that book that of course is
rather infamously about our one
president Donald Trump you did not even
think it was gonna be Hillary no I Lily
saw the Whig excuse me it was actually I
thought it was a wig behind the book I
got oh my god they got Kate McKinnon no
they got Hillary Clinton I was not
expecting you heard the reaction in the
room we haven't seen or heard a ton from
Hillary lately I was surprised in the
best way I don't think anyone expected
it I wouldn't be surprised if you were
not the only one who thought value yeah
they'd lost their mind
it was just one of many moments tonight
that deliver a very powerful message a
lot of people took the the platform
tonight at the Grammys to send a
specific message whether it was The
Times up movement Kendrick Lamar in
particular he kicked off the show with a
medley of his hits and I mean we could I
think I could sum it up in one word
which is the word of his album damn I
mean he really brought the fire there
was a Dave Chapelle cameo you too graced
the stage with him but really he was
delivering some political commentary I
think we have a from the performance I
mean this the title of the performance
was this is a satire by Kendrick Lamar
and it was really chilling it was a
scene of more than a dozen backup
dancers falling to the floor one by one
while gunshots rang so it was super
powerful and I I mean no better message
to be sent in from Kendrick Lamar right
what is sort of wonderful about the
night was that I think a lot of our
favorite performances actually had
really powerful messages behind them and
you guys again several of you saying
that you loved catches Ke$ha got up on
that stage with Cyndi Lauper with
Camilla Kibeho with some other artists
by her side an entire choir and sang her
song and of course Kesha has spoken out
about her you know alleged abuse that
has been really really tough to hear and
people have tried to rally around her
but that was before times up even
started I mean the Ke$ha was speaking
out so let's take a listen to her
performance
[Music]
Sophie you and I were talking about the
look on her face you speak about a
little bit I mean you could just tell
she was terrified but at the same time
she knew that this was such an important
moment and she really needed to deliver
I think she was probably feeling a lot I
can't I can't even imagine what she was
feeling up there but you could see on
her face that there was just so much
going on and of course right after she
finished performing just broke down in
tears sobbing surrounded by everyone
lots of hugs lots of love it was I had
chills I've another performance that
gave me goose bones for sure there was a
lot of yeah they cut to UM I think Haley
sign fell in the crowd and she was
crying because what we're really
watching is Kesha has had a journey a
personal and emotional but also
professional because she couldn't make
music for a while right and so this song
and her latest music represents her
being able to write her own music and
speak to what she's has been through and
celebrating her first Grammy nominations
I think part of that also was the
emotions of being on that stage you know
it's a huge feat for any artist and this
was her first time there so I'm sure
that had a lot to do with it and they
were on white and let's also remember
that tonight as a nod to the times of
movement which is mostly hit Hollywood
film TV and not as much the music
industry yet but many artists wore white
roses just as a nod to that movement
because it's a symbol of peace it was
used in the suffragette movement and
Ke$ha everybody was wearing white in
that performance so and I loved seeing
pink - actually wore white she wore just
a simple white t-shirt another powerful
woman and what I loved about Pink's
performance was that we're so used to
seeing her scaling buildings and doing
all these acrobats and for her to just
stand there in front of the microphone
just with that voice that huge voice
that's so incredible I thought it was
really moving and it wasn't what I
expected from her which I think it's
funny for somebody to stand there and
you're surprised because you usually
surprises us with those acrobatic
performances but she really shocked us
in this case by just stripping her face
I mean look at and the vocals I mean
that was pitch perfect oh yeah and I
think paignton always I mean we're pink
fans from back in a day she didn't
always have that powerhouse voice I
think she's someone who has really
trained herself vocally and gotten to
this place where all she has to do is
stay in front of a microphone and belt
and you're thinking
Wow one way to Ellis yes yeah I also
want to talk a little bit about
something that was a little more somber
actually so if you get your our country
music expert do you want to get into the
tribute to the Las Vegas shooting yeah
absolutely we had Maren Morris Eric
Church and brothers Osbourne all take
the stage
they performed Eric Clapton's tears in
heaven which was so incredibly moving
and they were paying tribute to victims
of concert violence throughout the year
of course all three of those acts were
performing at the route 91 Harvest
Festival in Las Vegas so it had
certainly a very special connection to
them it was just really emotional and I
loved at the backdrop it was all the
names of victims and I love that they
paid tribute to them in that way let's
take a look at this for a second yeah
that's Eric Clapton song tears from
heaven there it's it was beautiful yeah
and meirin's talked a lot I'm sorry
happy parent talk to us on the red
carpet and she kind of said that going
through that route 91 Harvest Festival
experience she felt like it really
connected her with her fans in a new way
and she said it was you know not an
ideal way but what she kind of took from
it is that no one's gonna stop loving
music no one's gonna stop going to
concerts so it's been really uplifting
to her in that way
I thought the Grammy struck a good chord
there was a nice balance between those
touching moments because obviously
they're hard to ignore but also it was a
lot of fun I know you guys are given a
lot of shoutouts to despots Itoh crystal
we see you that was definitely a lot of
fun uh Carly loved Lady gaga that was
another touching performance and Steven
loved and Rihanna and dj khaled I mean
we're gonna get into that too but I got
to give a shot to one of my other
favorite performances childish gambino
aka Donald Glover graced the stage in
this beautiful white suit but what was
amazing was the young man who shared the
stage with him is actually playing young
Simba in the live-action lankey
alongside Donald and of course Beyonce
as Nala oh we have a shot for you guys
and just take a listen because these two
wailed
that was just a taste it was really good
yeah right we should note you guys we
want to give you just a little taste
here but of course that we are breaking
out each of these moments and really
focusing them at all of our coverage of
ET online comm and getting into things
to know about that young man because he
is gonna be a breakout star
can I just say does does Donald Glover
have any other talents that we need just
casually you know like it creates his
own TV shows ones word for those albums
ones word for those like he's so amazing
score musical necks and gonna collect a
Tony I'm just gonna call it just so you
guys know that the young singers name is
JD McCreary watch out for him in like
like Lauren mention we were breaking
down everything you need to know about
him over at et Online back then you
mentioned Rihanna as did Steven Sophie
take us yeah she looked so good you guys
that dress I was just loving how she
filled it out as she was dancing and my
thing with her was that she just looked
happy she was having so much fun up
there and you know this award show there
were a lot of heavy moments there were a
lot of somber moments but I think they
balanced it with really fun upbeat
uplifting staff Rihanna look at how
beautiful she is
don't you I felt like this performance
embodied exactly where Rihanna is in her
life right now like if you got follow
her on social she's just enjoying
herself yes how long she's been famous
and worked so hard since such a young
age and she's just like I Know Who I am
now I'm gonna kill it
and we don't always get to see Rihanna
do full choreography but that's how you
know that's how you know that she at the
time yes she put in the rehearsal she
did that dance break through wall
thoughts and I was like full
choreography where's she's having a good
time tongue sticking out oh the fish I
loved it if there's one thing that Denny
notices it's the quarry we've always
kept that from RiRi you know she likes
to just you know do her sexy thing but
she has turned it out tonight her own
thoughts and collaboration with Kendrick
Lamar for loyalty so hey you know I do
think it's worth noting and some of you
guys are saying this we had a lot of
powerful performances by women fun
talent filled performances by women but
not a ton of big wins for women tonight
yeah I'm still a little upset that Ke$ha
didn't take pop vocal performance
and a lot of people have been noticing
that Ed Sheeran took that category it
was all women it was pink it was Kelly
Clarkson
I'm the other ones are escaping me but
they were all women and Ed Sheeran took
it so people were not really thrilled
about that Ed wasn't even there get two
Grammys congratulations very exciting
for him but I would have really liked to
see Kesha take that specific wine with
you I argue with you guys we're just
scratching the surface there is plenty
more to talk about of course we have
coverage going on all night long at eat
Yan lang calm but gotta plug my show
you guys have to join us tomorrow for
daily Deni live at 12 p.m. Pacific we're
gonna break down all the stuff you
didn't see on TV and of course Grammys
fashion like the Grammys red carpet
that's where you need to go looking at
the these dresses and the suits the guys
were turning out in I'll tell you guys
all about it tomorrow overall you guys I
thought such a great show I mean James
Corden was funny he was smart we had
powerful performances we had
performances that made all of us
literally lift our desks up we have
stood and we did yeah I mean Sophie
what's your take away there was a little
something for everybody which I loved we
had the new artists we had staying we
had u2 we I mean no matter what kind of
music you like or what age bracket you
fall into there was a little something
for you and I think the Grammys does
that better than anybody
yes I love that guys all right well yes
again check out Daley Denny alive
tomorrow and of course watch
Entertainment Tonight tomorrow where you
guys are gonna see backstage moments
that you didn't see on the show our
red-carpet moments and check out ET
online.com for more anything else just
gonna catch my breath
rehydrate
[Music]
you